[Music]
all through the evolution of mankind
there has been this constant
connection you can see why this tree is
almost dead a lot of things have
happened
to when I look out at the trees in my
backyard I think about
time this tree has been alive longer
than Nana and oh definitely than you
this is a vine it's gobbling everything
up it's just like there's a
war Timber it's always been a big thing
in my life after my
great-grandfather I don't know whether
it didn't lead to my kidnapping
too the first trees I photographed I was
just drawn to how fragile they are
[Music]
are it's called internment camp but it
was really a concentration camp if I can
bring life to this tree and then have
hope maybe one day we'll get
out my father bought my mother this
cherry blossom tree all the freedom that
he didn't have in the world he poured
into that
land cold heat fire volcano and the tree
could die but the tree could live be
gentle but it's always going to carry
the scar of it it's coming it's
coming just Builds on itself with time
to become this that's a
story that's a life well-
[Music]
lived